[Applause]
Ah ah
ah yeah yeah
[music]
hmm I don't think it's a perfect match b.
]
I see
, Shio, you're coming to
retire.  But I'm only thinking about hitting 10 and catching the top
.
I'd like to gather allies up to the same number as the enemy somehow
, but
continue at this company where 4 more people gathered
Sublime Centralia 6 is playing an arm game with everyone at the same store
[Music]
Kore Beauty Sprinkle
Open Open Hot water. 3rd seats
Negishi Mato
Susuke Among the surviving students, MAX has a fun destruction.
I'm here
Team 3 when Philo was on the side of the edge, I'm taking a rebellion against Atami Canal
Nakamura 10 times healed Mistake
No, Erina How
have you been?
How about 3 slots?